[Musik]
der klassische reichs bürger sagt die
bundesrepublik deutschland als staat
existiert nicht anstatt darf nur geführt
werden wenn er einen start ist
mehr wollen wir gar nicht von der maas
bis an die memel von der etsch fisch an
den welt der selbstverwaltung sagt
letztendlich ich bin der starb wir haben
eine grundlegende idee wir glauben eine
schöpfungsordnung und diese
schöpfungsordnung drückt sich in der
verfassung des königreichs deutschland
aus eine diskussion mit reichen bürgern
ist in der regel nicht möglich selber
sind ja nur beauftragt müssen jetzt
dieses interview machen da wir ziehen
reich bekannt ich will vielleicht
gebastelt klingt vielleicht auch nicht
meistens spielen die sich zu einer art
jurist auf meinen das gesetz besser zu
verstehen als diejenigen die gerade mit
dem geltenden gesetz operieren
sie wissen doch ganz genau dass der
ganze laden hier privatisiert ist das
wissen sie doch
haben sich gegen juden sie machen
werbung für die juden so einverstanden
antisemitismus ist die grundlage für die
reise bürgerbewegung und aus
antisemitismus und aus menschen
gedankengut entsteht immer gewalt
[Applaus]
für ihn war es gab explosionen
ich habe richtig die explosion ist
kommen wir auch nicht vorstellen
an den türen das schwarzfahren und
manche haben die
bezeichnet gewillt war wie im krieg das
haben wir nicht alltäglich von
polizisten
[Musik]